uh welcome back to sky news uh we are
getting live pictures that you can see
here uh
inside the plane that has just landed in
moscow
carrying the putin critic alexi navalny
he's
in the front right of the shot that's
the back of his head that you can see
there in that navy blue
hoodie and he's making that journey back
from
germany where he's been recovering from
a poisoning
in siberia some five months ago by a
novichok
nerve agent and is making this return
back to russia to who knows what sort of
reception uh he's been an outspoken as i
say critic
of uh president putin although the
kremlin continued to
dismiss him as a blogger and deny any
involvement
in that poisoning last month a number of
his supporters and allies have been
gathering at the main airport in moscow
where his plane was expected to land
around an hour ago police were riot
police were detaining
uh his supporters there and at the last
minute the
arrivals board at that airport indicated
that alexei navalny's plane had been
diverted
to another airport in the city
presumably so that the authorities could
underplay the significance of this
arrival we can speak now to
elena who is actually on board that
plane as you can see a number of
journalists on board that plane with
mr navalny alina tell us a little bit
about what's been happening during the
flight and what sort of reception mr
navalny can expect when he disembarks
yeah hi everyone everything is going
very messy here
a lot of people here and journalists all
the all during
the flight uh no one let him
uh no one gave him any space uh
right now journalists try to ask him
questions
he's not answering his press secretary
also
uh does give any comments so basically
during the flight
uh they were keeping silence
okay of course this is the first time
he'll have been on board a plane
uh conscious at least since the incident
that happened in siberia
some five months ago he became extremely
unwell and those images of him
groaning uh in pain were broadcast
around the world before
uh he was transported to germany for
treatment
just tell us a little bit about the the
last five months
and and that uh that package of uh
investigation that the germans have
handed to the russians about his
illness
i'm not sure if alina can still hear me
yes we can can you hear us alina having
a few problems with comms
yes could you please could you please
repeat a question
just tell us a little bit about what the
ordeal mr navalny has been through
and what he can expect waiting for him
uh so right now over here all of us we
expect that
he's gonna be arrested and we are still
in the plane
and he said that he is not scared
that he believes that uh
that he will reach the truth and that we
need to live in the
free country so he's ready to sacrifice
himself
and uh basically be arrested
his wife is around him right now and
right now we're leaving the plane so if
you're gonna be here
with me i can give you more updates
if he was arrested or not
tell us a little bit about what the mood
was on the plane we saw pictures
as he boarded the plane of his
supporters clapping
every everything was super hectic
uh people a lot of journalists here
so it was actually not even secure to
fly
because people who were
in the in one part of the plane he's
sitting on the c30
which is the middle of the plane luckily
yes
um however the captain two times said us
that it's not secure
that it's not secure to drive in these
conditions
okay and
if you give me a second i can give you
more information okay elena thank you
very much for that we'll stay on your
pictures for a moment or two
um but as you can see there for anybody
tuning in uh we are getting live
pictures of the moment
alexi navalny has stepped foot back
onto russian soil and what's been viewed
as a hugely
brave uh return to his home
country he's been a long uh standing
critic
of president putin and the kremlin and
as such has been uh the subject
uh of uh a poisoning which happened as i
say in
siberia some five months ago a huge
media circus around him there not only
on board that plane but on the
bus there which will presumably take him
now from the plane
uh to the terminal he's uh not
looking like he wants to say anything at
this stage but as he got onto the plane
and as alina was saying there he was
greeted initially
by a number of his supporters with
cheers and
claps